Hi Dr. Cutters, you recommended Blacksand Bloodroot after my cheek swab. Can you explain why and what it does?
So why I recommend anything after the cheek swab is because you tested for it. That's why you sent the cheek swab in.
So we tested for it, and that's what tested.
What does the Blacksand Bloodroot do? Well, the Blacksand Bloodroot, if you look on the store,
if you look at the label, it's got really good cancer-killing nutrients in it.
The Blacksand Bloodroot is primarily used as a quote-unquote cancer-killing product by
anybody who's using it. So it has similar, I think it's got chaperale and bloodroot and
graviola and something else. I don't have the label in front of me, but that's why you're using it.
I'm considering going off the cascuali that I have been on. I just found out after a CT scan
that a few small areas have grown just a bit after no change in many months. My lungs and my liver,
my lungs and my liver mainly. Is it an important change to start the immune in the Blacksap?
Yeah, yes, I do. I think it is an important thing to do. Yes, I have quit doing the vitamin C IV,
so I can afford the two of those. All right, yeah. You always want when you look at a CT scan,
you always want to get a comparison and look at how much of a change
in the cancer, how much of a growth, and it's always best again to go to the same place
and be great if you could go to this and have the same radiologist read it. You don't have no control
over that, but I always remember that when they're looking at a size of a lesion in the lung,
remember that they're not looking at a three-dimensional object, it is like multi-dimensional
and it's really hard to angle that they see it to really see. You'd want to see a fairly large
percentage of change to get worried about it.